today we're going to cancel
a lady on the view whose name apparently
is sarah though i don't know her last
name and i don't feel like looking it up
she earned herself applause and lots of
you go girls yesterday during a debate
over vaccine
passports sarah came out in favor of the
passports
and here is her reasoning let's listen i
i cannot argue
privacy on a public health issue like
this when i don't understand how the
most
private thing in my body my uterus seems
to be open for business
when it's convenient politically so i
will say that these passports are a
great idea
uterus open for business well
we don't need to know about that that's
your own concern um now
planned parenthood by the way of course
tweeted that clip out loved it
as i said lots of feminists expressed
their appreciation of her point there
i can't quite join them in their round
of applause though mostly because
that was extremely dumb and let's just
let's let's count the ways first of all
what exactly are you saying here sarah
that that you
you think you don't have privacy with
respect to abortion
so therefore nobody should have it with
respect to vaccinations
if i can't have privacy then nobody can
is that your position
i'll do you a favor and assume that that
wasn't your point
even though that was literally the point
you that you were making i'll assume
that you were in a clumsy way just
attempting to note what you perceive to
be
a contradiction you see it as
hypocritical or ironic that people who
oppose abortion
would also oppose vaccine passports but
the problem is that the hypocrisy and
irony actually runs
entirely the other way see there's
nothing contradictory about someone
arguing that
we shouldn't be forced to get vaccines
and also that we shouldn't be allowed to
kill our children
those two positions are in no way
whatsoever at odds with each other
i can advocate for privacy when it comes
to vaccines yet still say that you
shouldn't be granted the privacy to kill
your baby
you see i like i i can take i can
believe both of those things and i do
there's nothing logically unsound about
arguing that privacy should extend as
far as vaccines
but not as far as killing babies
meanwhile
you're professing a belief in privacy
rights that is so absolute
so radical that it even permits you to
kill your own child
but you don't think we should have the
privacy to decide what vaccines we take
you go from a privacy rights absolutist
to an anti-privacy absolutist you go
from
bodily autonomy extremism to chucking
bodily autonomy out the window
completely
you say that you have the privacy rights
and autonomy to kill a person
but not to decide what vaccines you put
in your body
you have taken the extremist position on
both
sides of these issues you have done that
what's happening here is something very
similar to what happens with the capital
punishment debate
right people who are anti-capital
punishment and pro-abortion
will point at the pro-capital punishment
and anti-abortion side and accuse
us of having a self-contradictory view
if we say we're pro-life then how can we
possibly support the execution of
criminals
but of course there's nothing remotely
contradictory or arbitrary about the
view that killing innocent and
defenseless children is wrong
yet executing convicted adult murderers
is right
one can believe it justified to execute
a man who say raped and killed a child
without also believing that it's
justified to crush an infant's skull in
the womb
those two positions are not at odds with
each other in fact they line up quite
logically and sensibly
we are so opposed to the murder of
innocent people
that we think the people who commit
those crimes may in some cases be
eligible for the harshest punishment
it's see it's it's our for for those and
not every pro-life person is in favor of
the death penalty by the way many are
not but
as someone who who is i will say it is
partially
my conviction my belief in the value of
human life
that causes me to be in favor of the
death penalty
because i consider it to be such a
heinous
act to kill an innocent person
that the harshest available punishment
should be applied to you you may not
agree with this point of view but to
pretend that it's incoherent is silly
it's a perfectly coherent point of view
i'll tell you what is incoherent it is
incoherent to say
that a child killing rapist or
a serial killer has a right to live but
a baby
doesn't have a right to live it's
incoherent to treat the execution of a
convicted murderer some great injustice
and yet to celebrate the execution of
infants
once again the contradiction the moral
insanity is all on the other side
even though i'm used to it i still can't
help but be almost shocked at the
gumption
of the pro-abortion side that they would
accuse us of being moral hypocrites
when they're the ones who support
executions only for the youngest and
most defenseless among us
that position is simply not not
defensible itself
second point for our friend sarah just a
sort of a technical point
sarah claims as all pro boards do that
pro-lifers are somehow
trying to control her uterus well let me
allay those
concerns sarah and tell you that we
don't care about your uterus
we're not the ones talking about it you
guys are the ones who are constantly
talking about your uterus is
and other assorted body parts you're the
one always bringing it up
and it's really weird i gotta say it's
very weird for us because
that's not what we're trying to talk
about like we're talking about abortion
and then you weirdos come running in
what are you doing talking about my body
and my uterus we're not calm down
that's not the conversation we're
looking to have our point is not about
your body
it's not about you actually if you can
believe it you're narcissist
it's about the body of your child and
the only point we're making about the
body of your child is that one
your child's body is not your body
they're two separate distinct entities
and
two you shouldn't have the right to
destroy your child's body
that's it that's all we're saying yes
your child's body is dependent upon your
body but that doesn't make his body the
same as
your body and it doesn't make it okay to
kill him
just because somebody is dependent upon
you that doesn't mean that you should be
able to kill that person if it did
that would mean that parents would have
the right to kill their children way
beyond the womb
infants babies toddlers adolescents even
some grown adults
are dependent on their parents for
survival a newborn baby
speaking of newborns is nearly as
dependent on his mother's body
out of the womb as he was inside it
do you think that that gives you the
right to bash your newborn skull
you know against a rock and throw him in
a dumpster
i would hope not most of us recognize
that parents have a responsibility to
their born
children we compel them right we compel
them by law
by force to care for their children we
say to parents
you have to you don't have a choice you
have to care for your children
if you can't or you don't want to you
have to find someone who will you have
to make other arrangements
may not be difficult to do you know you
put them up for adoption some states
make it easier than others
for parents to um offload their kids
and find someone else to to care for
them but whatever the process there's
gonna be there's a process in place
right and you have to follow it
if you don't you'll go to prison what
you can't do is just leave your kid on
the side of the road
least of all can you simply kill your
child
right the point of pro-lifers is that
this principle the principle that you
are responsible to
and for your child and don't have the
right to intentionally harm your child
should apply in the womb just as much as
it does outside of it that's a
consistent view that is a rationally
defensible view that's a morally salient
view
which is more than i can say about your
position a position that is as logically
incoherent as it is morally deranged
a position that today has earned you the
title of
cancelled listen hit that subscribe
button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated